hello so we begin with breaking news
from Ukraine where several explosions
have rocked the capitol cave in several
other cities the state Emergency
Services says there have been deaths and
injuries although it's not clear yet how
many they reported Russian strikes are
the First on Kiev in many months blasts
have also been heard in multiple cities
in Ukraine's West leviv which is close
to the Polish border and turnopiel the
nepro in central Ukraine and close to
the front lines has also been hit
let's bring in Rory challenge who's
following developments for us from Keith
he's joining us on the phone Rory so
multiple strikes in central Kiev and
right across Ukraine this morning tell
us what happened and what you heard and
saw
well I think we're going through at
least a third wave of rockets coming in
right now there have been many many
explosions in Kiev this morning uh I've
just in the last minute or so counted
three uh rumbles uh not too close to
where we are at the moment but certainly
not too far away either uh the second
wave came in about 20 minutes ago two
very large explosions uh near to where
we are remember this is Monday morning
so these attacks seem designed to cause
Maximum Carnage during the morning Rush
Hour basically there are injured and
dead but it's not yet known how many
that's according to the state's
Emergency Services the early indications
are that eight people have been killed
but that was an hour ago before the
latest waves of attack so that is almost
certain to go up significantly now key
of city mayor vidali Klitschko has
appealed to all residents in the city he
says stay in shelters and if there's no
urgent need it's better not to go into
the city at all Central streets um have
basically been blocked off by police so
that emergency services can work the
Metro system is down this is something
that here as a city is the capital city
hasn't experienced um for months other
cities have been hit over recent stays
and and weeks but Kiev has largely been
spared to this kind of thing since the
summer at least and people had really
stopped paying attention to the air raid
sirens I think it's a very very
different reality uh in Kiev this Monday
morning yeah Rory so as you're saying
the capital has not been hit for some
time now so this will be very troubling
for people in key won't it
yeah absolutely I mean this will change
uh the calculus uh change uh the way in
people at which people go around their
daily business
um you know other other parts of the
country uh have been hit much more
frequently than Kiev has in in recent uh
in recent months and and weeks but you
know over the the country today this
morning there seems to be pretty much no
major urban center that that isn't being
hit by missiles at the moment there have
been strikes in Cardiff labiv nepro
legitimir turnip Hill uh overnight Zappa
regia with hit two but that has had many
many strikes in it uh in recent days
I mean some of the attack seem to have
been on Industrial and Civic
infrastructure like electricity stations
and rail Etc but a lot of it seems to be
pretty indiscriminate just you know
coming down
in streets uh and he centers the the
president zielinski um has just put out
a statement and he says that they're
trying to destroy us and wipe us off the
face of the Earth
um they're trying to destroy our people
who are sleeping at home uh kill people
who go to work in dinitro and Kiev and
the air raid alarm doesn't subside
throughout the Ukraine that basically
means that you know this is going on
across the country there are missiles
hitting unfortunately there are dead and
wounded please do not leave shelters
take care of yourself and your loved
ones let's go on and be strong I think
there's no doubt here in Ukraine that
this is Vladimir Putin's revenge for the
Kirsch bridge and he's taking it out on
the softest targets there are which is
civilians uh Rory just one more for you
while I have you with us I wonder if you
can tell us a little bit more about the
whether there were specific targets that
were hit in Kiev
well I mean in key of the videos that
I've seen obviously we're not going out
in the streets at the moment because
it's absolutely not safe at all to do so
but the videos that I'm I'm looking at
at the moment show uh a strike right
next to a playground a huge crater next
to uh next to a playground in Township
Park right in the middle of downtown
um so that's not exactly a strategic
Target is it uh there are you know video
showing burning cars University
buildings
um near government buildings perhaps so
but that might have been what the
intended target was but you know these
are not obviously not particularly
precise weapons that are being used at
the moment so they're coming down pretty
haphazardly
um on different different sorts of
environments but you know certainly in
the middle of a built up city like
you've you're gonna kill civilians if
you launch these kinds of things okay
Rory we'll let you go for now thank you
so much for that update Rory challenge
reporting from Keith
well earlier the Russian President
Vladimir Putin called the blast on the
bridge connecting Crimea to Mainland
Russia a terrorist act the Russian
president blamed Ukraine's special
services he set to hold a meeting of
Russia's Security Council later on
Monday the Kirch Bridge supplies
moscow's troops in southern Ukraine and
is seen as a symbol of Russian power in
the region Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility
there is no doubt this is an act of
terrorism aimed at destroying Russia's
critical civilian infrastructure its
authors perpetrators and beneficiaries
are the security services of Ukraine
so that was the Russian president
speaking earlier on we're just taking
you to the live picture right now in
Kiev that's coming to us right here at
Al Jazeera we've been reporting that
several explosions have rocked not only
the capital in Ukraine but several other
cities right across the country the
state Emergency Services say there have
been deaths and injuries were not clear
yet on the exact numbers we'll get you
those numbers as and when we get them uh
right here at Al Jazeera so these are
the live pictures from the capitol cave
where as you can see that is the
aftermath of several explosions that
have rocked the city early Monday
morning let's bring in now she's joining
us from denipro Odessa there have been
multiple strikes across the country
including we understand in dinipro where
you are tell us what you heard
yeah certainly it started about uh 7 00
a.m We heard the first loud explosion
followed by a series of explosion and
the last one as we understand it was
about 10 to 15 minutes ago it was it's
happening more or less at the same time
uh when it started in even this is
certainly the largest attack ever on
Benito uh since uh the war started now
also in the provisions had been several
uh stripes and impressive
those cities have come increasingly uh
under attack the students of region are
nearly on a daily basis and quite Deadly
Ones uh just yesterday uh 20 people died
on a residential building was hit
um so they had been anxiety in this part
of the country that these airstrikes
were
increasing and more more civilian
targets were being hit now we don't have
the full picture of what happened
Indonesia at the moment you know that at
least one residential building was made
but the rest the local authorities are
still not giving us any indication of
what's happening I can tell you that for
the first time that I am in this city uh
people are down in the shelter worried
and wondering uh what's going to happen
next because for the Negro this is the
first time this city comes after under
such a large scale attack yeah and Rory
was reporting how troubling this is for
people in the capital key because Kiev
itself hasn't been hit for uh for a long
time so again this must be very
troubling for people in in denipro
it is very troubling and I would say
that it's not only something for the
people underneath us it's also troubling
for the people in the parija even though
they had been targeted uh more often uh
lately I think when an air siren goes
off uh people are in anxiety you don't
know where the missile is gonna land if
it lands if it's going to be intercepted
and one person in that region just a
couple of days ago was telling me that
each time this air series goes off she
feels like a shooting duck not knowing
where to go what to do because it could
be anywhere at any time and often the
ones that actually do hit a Target and
go undetected by the air Sirens
um the Russians have been using a
missile called the s-300 which was
supposed to be a ground to air missile
which they adapted to ground to ground
missile it's a hypersonicism and it
often goes under from the air siren so
it's usually very troubling uh moments
very scary moments and I think whether
you've been in a city that has already
been struck several times or like in
Junipero who has seen a few strikes but
certainly not on this scale it is very
scary for everyone involved so could
people be worried now that this
signifies a a significant escalation
then in the war
yes
it does signify lesson because of the
installation I don't think it comes as a
surprise
um on the ground the Russian uh forces
have been uh obliged to retreat for
example from the north east and the
Khaki region they've also been pushed a
bit in the lugan's region they've also
been incuring the seats in the brunettes
region so there was an expectation that
at some point Russia
will respond it has the air superiority
and so people would say that they were
expecting this especially that as I said
earlier cities cities like kharkiv and
zafarija and also nipro was said A week
ago and there were several civilians
that were killed in that attack people
were expecting more of that and I think
last night also when the Russian
president reading the opinion uh sort of
pointed the finger for the first time
since the attack on the cursed bridge in
Crimea and he pointed the finger at
Ukraine
um I think people
okay thank you so much for that update
from deniper Abdul Hamid there and once
again that is the live picture from Kiev
the aftermath of several explosions that
have rocked uh not only the capital this
morning Kiev but also several cities
right across Ukraine and we have heard
from a of the presidential Aid to
Ukrainian president zielinski saying
this quoting I'm quoting that the new
Russian rocket strikes are another
signal to the Civilized world world that
the Russian question must be solved by
force we will bring you all the latest
information out of Ukraine as and when
we get it right here on Al Jazeera